[موسيقى]
اهلا بكم مشاهدينا الى ملفات الخامسه من
العربيه والبدايه في ابرز العناوين
وسط انباء عن عمليه عسكريه من روسيا روسيا
تقيم قاعده عسكريه على تماس مع القوات
التركيه شمال سوريا بسبب العمليه العسكريه
التركيه
تتواعدوا باستخدام اسلحه جديده
للدفاع الجوي
[تصفيق]
وسلطات
الايرانيها الكرويين وتهددهم بالقتل
واعمل ملفات الخمسه ايضا ازمه تويتر
تتواصل مسؤول سابق في تويتر يحذر المنصه
بات في خطر وسبب ديكتاتوريه مصر
اهلا بكم البدايه من التطورات في شمال
سوريا ومع الحديث عن عمليه عسكريه بريه
تركيه وشيكه في المنطقه انشات القوه
الروسيه قاعده عسكريه قبله قاعده عسكريه
تركيه في ريف حلب الشرقي في قريه تل جيجان
وفقا لمرصد السوري لحقوق الانسان كما افاد
المرصد انها المره الاولى التي تنتشر فيها
القوات الروسيه على خط تماس مع القوات
التركيه وعزت وجودها العسكريه بالجرود
والمدافع والمواد اللوجستيه
ونبقى في سوريا حيث شدد مسؤولون محليون
اكراد في شمال وشرق البلاد في بيان على ان
الخطر الذي تتعرض له مراكزها يمتد ليشمل
تهديد المنطقه باكملها مشيره الى ان هذا
الخطر لن يزول الا باتخذه مواقفه حازمه من
الدول الضامنه تجاه سياسه العدائيه
التركيه حسب البيان البيان واشار الى ان
الهجوم التركيه المحتمل يشمل المراكز التي
تضم عناصر من تنظيم داعش وبعد الاعلان من
قبل المكتب عن حاله تاهب وسط فار القصوى
اشار الى ان الهجمات التركيه تستهدف تهجير
اهالي المنطقه وانشاء ما وصفه بانه بيئه
خصبه لتنظيم داعش
ومن انجلترا ينضم الينا مدير المرصد
السوريه لحقوق الانسان السيد رامي عبد
الرحمن مرحبا بك سيد رامي هل نحن نتحدث عن
بدء العد تنازلي لبدء هذه العمليه
العسكريه البريه التركيه بالفعل
الخير
ولكن حتى اللحظه لا يوجد اي قوات عسكريه
تركيه على الحدود روحي بان العمليه
العسكريه سوف تبدا من ذلك
تعزيزات للقوات الروسيه لقوات النظام
للمشاكل
في ريف حلب الشمالي على سبيل المثال لاول
مره روسيا
روسيه في منطقه الرفعات قاعده قرب القاعده
التركيه التي يريد حلب الشمالي ايران او
ما تعرف المنشات
ادخل الدبابات في تفعيل همم الى مطار
العسكري اي ان التعديلات وصلت الى هذه
البقعه التي تحدث عنها اردوغان اولا فهي
منطقه
في منطقه عين العرب كوباني هناك همم يعني
ظهور واضح للرؤوس الاعلام الروسيه ترفع
بشكل كبير جدا في المناطق المحيطه في في
البلده التي صددت في وجه تنظيم الدوله
الاسلاميه سابقا ولا تزار صامده وايضا
انتشار لقوات النظام في ريف كوباني الغربي
واليوم نشرنا شريط مصور يظهر قيام القوات
الروسيه بعمليه يعني همم استطلاع وتفقد
لقوات النظام المنتشره في المنطقه ما بين
طل ابيض وكوباني ايريك كوباني الشرقي لا
يوجد ما يوحي بان العمليه العسكريه
التركيه باتت على الابواب القرار على ما
يبدو بيد اردوغان خسران هو الذي سيختار ما
بين عمليه عسكريه او الدخول في مفاوضات مع
الروس من اجل الوصول الى حلول الماء يخرج
منها همم يعني يحفظ ماء وجهي بعد التوعد
ارارا وتكرارا بشان عمليه عسكريه
ان الضوء الاخضر من واشنطن لم يصدر بعد
لهذه العمليه لان هناك تصريحات من قوات
سوريا الديمقراطيه ان هناك وعود واضحه من
واشنطن بان هذه العمليه لن
يعني يعني نتحدث الوعود واشنطن بالاساس
كنا لا يوجد ضوء اخضر لا روسي ولا امريكي
بالنسبه للولايات المتحده الامريكيه هي
غير معنيه في منطقه عين العرب كوباني كونت
واجد من الرموز اكثر من وجود الامريكيين
الامريكيين قد يكون وجودا استخباراتهم
الاستخباراتيه لكن لا يوجد ضوء اخضر
امريكي بشكل قطع اليه جده الاخضر الامريكي
وحتى الضوء الاخضر الروسي
من التاسعه عشر من الشهر الجاري ليلا
وصولا الى همم يعني التاسع والعشرين فجرا
ان تتوقف العمليات الجويه التركيه في تلك
المنطقه وانا قلت على شاشه الحدث حقيقه
امر في السبع والعشرين ان السماء 48 ساعه
القادمه ستم هل هناك عمليه عسكريه بالعدده
الى الان لا ضوء اخضر لا اردوغان لاحد
فيما من اردوغان ذاته
العسكريه التي اقامتها روسيا تفاصيل هذه
القاعده اين تقع طبيعه التعزيزات العسكريه
التي يمكن ان تتم من خلالها الى اي
المناطق يمكن ان تعزز هذه القاعده الوضع
العسكري
نعم
ريف حلب الشمالي يوجد بلدتين
الايراني
بالتقدم في تلك المنطقه لانها لا تريد
حاضنتها الشعبيه في تلك المنطقه روسيا
ايضا لا تريد ان تسمح لي اردوغان بالسيطره
على تلك المنطقه انشاء قاعده عسكريه في
ثلج شان مقابل قاعده عسكريه تركيه في قريه
عدنان في تلك المنطقه ايضا قلت لك بان
تعزيزات مدفعيه بعيده المدى وصلت الى تلك
المنطقه تحديثات عسكريه للقوات الروسيه
ليست دوريات فقط وتعزيزات عسكريه لقوات
النظام ومن الشات الايراني ايضا في ريف
عين العرب مباني عندما نقول بان الدوريات
الروسيه جون هذه الرساله لاردوغان باننا
لن نسمح بعمليه عسكريه اضافه لسانه واكثر
من الروس والايرانيين والنظام هناك روح
المقاومه لدى ابناء كوباني هناك رفض رفض
بالنزوح عن مدينتهم لان النزوح يعني يعني
يفهموا القتال 30 داعش
الذي سيدهم
تفضل نعم السيد رامي عبد الرحمن مدير
المرصد السوري لحقوق الانسان شكرا لك
ونذهب الى تطورات الحرب الروسيه
الاوكرانيه ففي تطورات اوكرانيا قال وزير
الخارجيه الامريكيه بلانكن ان استراتيجيه
رئيس الروسيه بلاد مير بوتين لم ولن تنجح
اضافه بل يمكن خلال مؤتمر صحفي في بوخارست
ان روسيا تقصف منشات الكهرباء والمياه في
اوكرانيا التي تحولت الى اهداف جديده
موضحا ان روسيا قصفت في الاسابيع الاخيره
اكثر من ثلث منشات الطاقه في اوكرانيا في
معتبره بلانكن عملا همجيا وزير الخارجيه
الامريكيه اكد ايضا ان بلاده ستواصل دعمها
لاوكرانيا تتطالما تطلب الامر ذلك وايد
التواصل لسلام عادل ودائن في اوكرانيا
مضيفا ان بوتين غير معنيه حاليا
دبلوماسي جدي لحل الازمه
من جانبي هي طالبه وزير الخارجيه
الاوكرانيبا بتزويد بلاده بدبابات غربيه
في اسرع وقت ممكن وقال كلبا خلال اجتماعه
مع وزير الخارجيه الامريكيه انتن بلانكن
ان بلاده تبحث مع المانيا سبل تزويدها
بمنظومه الصاروخيه واشار رئيس الدبلوماسيه
الاوكرانيه الى ضروره بدي محادثات انضمام
اوكرانيا
ستصبح عضوا في الحلف وذكر وزير الخارجيه
الاوكرانيه ان مدير الوكاله الذريه سيواصل
مساعه بشان انشاء من طاقه امنه في محطه
النوويه
المفوضيه العروبيه بدورها اقترحت انشاء
محكمه متخصصه لتحقيق في جرائم الحرب في
اوكرانيا بما في ذلك الدمار الذي سببت
روسيا للبنيه التحتيه
ان تدفع ثمن جرائمها المروعه بما في ذلك
جريمه العدوان على دوله ذات السياده مع
استمرارنا في دعم المحكمه الجنائيه
الدوليه فاننا نقترح انشاء محكمه متخصصه
مدعومه من الامم المتحده للتحقيق في جريمه
العدوان الروسي ومقضات مرتكبها مستعدونا
لبدء العمل مع المجتمع الدولي للحصول على
اوسع دعم دوليا ممكن لهذه المحكمه
المتخصصه ويجب على روسيا ايضا ان تدفع
ماليا مقابل الدمار الذي تسببت به
في غضون ذلك على وزير الدفاع الروسيه
لوضع استراتيجيه النوويه العمليه ومشدده
في عام 20 23 وطول اهتماما خاصه بها واضاف
خلال مؤتمر عسكري ان روسيا ستعمل على
استخدام اسلحه حديثه ومتطوره خلال
العمليات العسكريه الخاصه في اوكرانيا كما
ستختبر طرقا جديده لاستخدام القوات
المدفعيه والصاروخيه والمسيرات اوكرانيا
العسكريه في اوكرانيا نستخدم انظمه
الاستطلاع والاطلاق منها المركبات المسيره
والاسلحه المتطوره عند اعداد قائمه
المنشات البناء الرئيسيه لعام 2023 سيتم
الاهتمام بالبناء لصالح القوات النوويه
الاستراتيجيه
ومعنا من موسكو السيد بابل بالجنهاور
المحلل العسكري مرحبا بك سيد بابل معنا
على شاشه العربيه ما الذي يعنيه هذا
التصريح لوزير الدفاع الروسيه في فكره
استخدام اسلحه حديثه في الحرب في اوكرانيا
وهناك اسلحه جديده قد ظهرت
ومسيرات البعض منها لعله ياتي من ايران
وصواريخ ايضا
وزير
قطاعه الدفاع العسكري في روسيا لا يزال
ينتج بعض الاسلحه المتطوره
اليها قد يكون من باب الحمله الدعاء حول
بعض الاسلحه الجديده التي تستخدم الامر
الذي من شانه ان يغير من سوره المعركه هذا
ما يقوله القائد العسكري في جميع الاحوال
عندما تكون قوته في صميم الحرب
وعندما يقوم دائما يقولوا باننا سوف نحقق
النصر ونعمل ان يحدث ذلك
انتصار عسكري روسي في اوكرانيا بل على
العكس ما تم به تزويد اوكرانيا باسلحه من
قبل على الغرب ادى الى قلب المعادله
العسكريه لصالحي اوكرانيا ماذا ترى
المعركه كانت تمتلك الروسيا كانت تمتلك
روسيا المبادره
وبعد ذلك باتت كفت الميزان في شهر اغسطس
تميل الى اوكرانيا التي امتلكت زمام
المبادره وبدات بدفع القوات الروسيه ودحر
هما ده حدا بروسيا الى تعزيز الدفاعاتها
وقد تكون الحاله الان اشبه بوضع الجمود في
ميدان المعركه بسبب اقتراب فصل الشتاء
ومع قدومه هذا همم فصل الشتاء سوف يقوم
سوف يتم تجميد كافه المناطق التي تكون ذات
طبيعه طينيه وتقوم القوات الروسيه بتحري
القوات الاوكرانيه التي تقدمته في الفتره
الحاليه ان هدف روسيا هو التوصل لوقف
اطلاق النار على المواقع التي احتلتها
روسيا بمعنى تجميد الصرا ما هو عليه هذا
قد يكون هو الهدف الرئيسي
والسينارو الافضل لروسيا ولكن
اسلحه حديثه وتطالب بدبابات ويتم الاعلان
عن تزويد امريكا لها بانظمه الدفاع متطوره
هل هذا يعني اننا امام فصل جديد من فصول
العمليه العسكريه في اوكرانيا
بشاني الاسلحه الجديده التي
هذه صور مباشره من امام السفاره
الاوكرانيه في مدريد حيث تبدو هناك انباء
عن انفجار في محيط هذه السفاره هذه صوره
تاتينا من مدريد من امام مقر السفاره
الاوكرانيه هناك على ما يبدو هناك حاله
تاهب في محيط هذه السفاره الانباء تشير
الى اصابه موظفه بهذا الانفجار
هذا الانفجار وكما تشاهدون وقع في محيط
السفاره الاوكرانيه في مدريد
ونجم عن رساله موفخه وفقا لما نشراته
رويترز الان نحن متابع مع حضراتكم هذه
الصور المباشره من مدريد حيث هذا الانفجار
الذي حدث وفقا رويترز نتيجه رساله مفخخه
ثم فتحها وتسريبها الى داخل السفاره مما
ادى الى اصابه موظفه داخل السفاره
الاوكرانيه في مدريد
تعزيزات امنيه كما نشاهد الان في محيط
السفاره الاوكرانيه في مدريد
اليك مره اخرى كنا نتحدث عن مطالب
اوكرانيا باسلحه جديده مطالب اوكرانيا
ايضا لامريكا بانظمه دفاع متطوره هل يعني
هذا اننا امام فصل جديد من العمليات
العسكريه سيعطي ملامح جديده لاستمرار هذه
الحرب
سوف تتوقفوا على نشهده في حمله الشتاء في
شهر ديسمبر ويناير ظهرت اسلحه جديده
وكانت سلفا امريكا ببعض الصواريخ
ذات المدن المتوسط وهناك مطالبات واحاديث
عن منظومه لكن المشكله بان همم العسكريين
في اوكرانيا غير متدربين على استخدامها
اذا ما كان هناك طواقم من حلف النيته سوف
يعملون على استخدامها مما يفضي الى تصعيد
كبير لكن
الانظمه الدفاعيه سوف تقدم او سوف يزج بها
خلف خطوط المواجهه لحمايه بعض المدن
الرئيسيه
وغيرهم من الصواريخ داخل المدى الطويل
الروسيه هذا الامر لن يغير كثيرا من واقع
الحال في ميدان المعركه سيد بابل فيجن
هاور المحل العسكري من موسكو شكرا لك على
وجودك معنا على شاشه العربيه ونعود مره
اخرى لمتابعه الانفجار الذي وقع في
السفاره الاوكرانيه في مدريد هذا الانفجار
وقع قرب السفاره واداء الى اصابه موظفه
نتيجه رساله مفخخه وفقا لما نشرته وكاله
روزرز للانباء وزير الخارجيه الاوكرانيه
كوليبا يطالب بزياده حمايه المباني
الدبلوماسيه لاوكرانيه بعد هذا الانفجار
في مدريد هناك همم حاله من التاهب الامني
كما نشاهد في محيط هذه السفاره سفاره
اوكرانيا في مدريد وسط مطالبات من وزير
الخارجيه الاوكرانيه ديمتريكوليبا بضروره
فتحي تحقيق لمعرفه تفاصيل اكثر حول هذا
الانفجار الانباء تشير الى ان هذا
الانفجار وقع نتيجه رساله مفخخه
لما تسليمها للسفاره الاوكرانيه في مدريد
لا حديث الان عن اصابات او اا وفيات سوى
اصابه واحده
لموظفه في السفاره حاله التاهب الامني في
محيط السفاره هي التي تسيطر بشكل واضح على
المشهد وفقا الصور التي نراها الان الشرطه
الاسلاميه قالت انه سيتم فتح تحقيق حول
هذا الانفجار بهذه الرساله لنفخخه الى
السفاره الاوكرانيه في مدريد على ما يبدو
هذا هو الهجوم الاول من نوعه الذي يستهدف
مقر الدبلوماسي ل- ااكرانيا وهذا ربما
يعطي بعض المؤشرات عن طبيعه تطورات الخاصه
بالحرب الروسيه الاوكرانيه ليست عمليه
عسكريه في داخل الاوكراني فقط ولكن الان
يتم الحديث عن هذه الاستهدافات لمقرات
دبلوماسيه اوكرانيه ومن قبل كان هناك ايضا
عمليات اغتيال لشخصيات حاطه روسيه داعمه
لنظام بوتين في همم عمليه الاغتيال
الشهيره التي تمت والتي توفيت على اثرها
ابنه كاتب روسي قريب من بوتين بشكل كبير
نحن امام تطورات تتعلق بالحرب الاوكرانيه
الروسيه ولكن من جهه اخرى في استهداف
بعمليات ارهابيه لبعض المقرات ادبلوماسيه
هو في ظل هذه التطورات كشفت وكاله نفيستي
ان رئيس جهاز المخابرات الخارجيه الروسيه
سرجي نرجسكي نقش القضايا النوويه وملف
اوكرانيا في اجتماع في وقت سابق من هذا
الشهر مع مدير وكاله المخابرات المركزيه
الامريكيه ويليامبرنس القائم باعمال
السفاره الامريكيه في موسكو اكد للوكاله
ان المسؤول الامريكي لم يتفوق بخصوص اي
شيء ولم يناقش تسويه النزاع في اوكرانيا
ونتاب بعيدا من الازمه في اوكرانيا الى
الاوضاع بالمحيط الهادي فقد اعلنت وزاره
الدفاع الروسيه ان قاذفات الاستراتيجيه
للقوات الجويه الروسيه والقوات الجويه
الصينيه قامت بتسير دوريه مشتركه فوق بحر
اليابان وبحر الصين الشرقيه واشارت وزاره
الدفاع الروسيه الى ان المقاتلات تصرفت
وفقا للقانون الدولي ولم تنتهك المجال
الجويه لاي دوله بالمنطقه وكانت كوريا
الجنوبيه اكدت ان المقاتلات الروسيه
والصينيه اخترقت اجوائها وان سلاح الجو
الكوري رد باطلاق مقاتلته
ونبقى معكم في سياق نشره الخامسه من
العربيه ولدينا
الجماهير السعوديه والعربيه تترقب مباراه
الحسن لبلوغ الدور الثاني والمنتخب
التونسي يواجه حامل اللقب
اهلا بكم من جديد
الى قرار مجلس حقوق الانسان التابع للامم
المتحده الاسبوع الماضي مبدع
النظام الايراني
انه يتوقع من لجنه تقص الحقائق بشان
احتجاجات ايران ان تتوسل الى قائمه باسماء
وتشاركها مع مسؤولين قانونيين وطنينا
واقليمين كان مجلس حقوق الانسان التابعه
للامم المتحده وافق في اجتماع خاص بشان
ايران على قرار يتم بموجبه تشكيله لجنه
دوليه قص الحقائق حول انتهاكات حقوق
الانسان خلال الاحتجاجات الايرانيه
الى ذلك اكد نجم كره القدم الايراني
السابق علي كريم تعرضه للتهديد بالقتل من
قبل سلطات الايرانيه لدعمه الاحتجاجات
الشعبيه والتضامنه مع المتظاهرين
الايرانيين الذين يحتاجون ضد النظام
الايراني الحاكم كريم بات صوتا دائما
للاحتجاجات الشعبيه من خارج ايران وكشف
خلال مقابله اجرتها معه باللغه الفارسيه
عبر قناه ماكس ميمي بموقع يوتيوب كشف عن
تعرض عائلته واصدقائه المقربين للترهيب
والمضايقه من قبل الحكومه الايرانيه
وينضم الينا من امستردام الباحث في الشان
الايرانيه يعقوب سعيد مرحبا بك سيد يعقوب
هناك بعض المخاوف التي يبديها المبعوث
الخاص بحقوق الانسان الايراني من مساله
ادانه مجلس حقوق الانسان الدولي
الانتهاكات واختراقات ايران فيما يتعلق
بالقمع مع الاحتجاجات الدائره حتى اللحظه
هذا يعني كان النظام لا يعطي اهتماما باي
حال من الاحوال الى هذه الاذنات الدوليه
تحيه طيبه لك قناه العربيه بالفعل والنظام
الايراني قرر اغلاق وثنيه لاي للمطالب
الداخليه والمطالب الخارجيه لان النظام
الايراني يعتقد بان المطالب من الاصلاحات
داخل هذا النظام هي حلقات مرتبطه ببعضها
فاذا استجاب لواحد قد يضطر للاستجابه الى
اخر هذه المطالبه وبالتالي قد يؤدي ذلك
الى همم الكثير من المشاكل بالنسبه لنظام
وقد حتى يؤدي الى اسقاط النظام ذاته هكذا
هكذا يعتقد النظام وهكذا تعتقد غالبا
لانظمه التوريه ولكن فعلا
هي ليست ناجمه عن عدم فاذا ما قرانا ما
بين الصقور الصحافه الايرانيه وكذلك
التصريحات المسؤولين ايرانيين اخرهم رئيس
السلطه القضائيه الذي هدد كل من ينشر
معلومات كاذبه عن الاحتجاجات بعقوبات
قاسيه نرى بان النظام الايراني يهيئ
لاعدامات جماعيه في المستقبل القريب وكان
التاريخ يعيد نفسه لان النظام الايراني
قضيه الاعدامات الشهيره
النظام الايراني وخاصه الرئيس الحالي
ابراهيم رئيس لديه تاريخ وبع طويل في هذا
المجال في عام 1988 قات محاكم عسكريه
سريعه وموجزه قام من خلالها باعدامات
جماعيه سريعه لاكثر ما بين ما بين 5000
شخص الى 8000 شخص داخل ايران وهذا ادى الى
اسكان الاصوات المعارضه للنظام في تلك
الفتره فلذلك اعتقد بانه ايضا التاريخ سوف
يعيد نفسها بالمستقبل القريب واعتقد ايضا
بانه على ال ال
مجالس الامم المتحده ومجالس الحقوق
الانسان
انت تتدخل بشان اكبر من ذلك اكثر من جمع
اسماء المعتقلين او كذا لانه هؤلاء
الاشخاص هم ليسوا فقط اسماء هؤلاء الاشخاص
كيانات لهم وجودهم كان لهم حياتهم واقرباء
وبالتاليمات النظام الايراني ايضا لا
يكتفي بالاعدامات خلال هذه الاحتجاجات
ابتدع وابتكر اساليب جديده لاغتيال
المعارضين مثل همم
قتل الاشخاص تحت التعذيب او
زوج النساء من على الاسطح فبالتالي هذه
الاساليب الجديده
للراي العام العالمي نجد تظاهرات تؤيد هذه
الاحتجاجات نج- نجد مواقف دوليه في الداخل
وفي الخارج ايضا لاعب كره القدم وما
يتعرضون له سواء من المنتخب او من خارجه
لارهاب شديد هل تعتقد الى ان هذه
الممارسات يمكن ان تؤدي الى وقفه من
الحكومات الدوليه بشكل قاطع ايران
هذا ما نتمناه وهذا ما نعول عليه لانه
الصوره ايران همم امام الراي العام
العالمي ما بعد الثوره ما بعد 16 سبتمبر
هي مختلفه عن صوره ايران ما قبل هذا
التاريخ الان سوره ايران على انه النظام
المجرم الذي يقتل شعب الذي يقتل النساء في
ال- في الشوارع قتل اكثر من 60 طفلا هذه
الصوره تكرست لدى الراي العام الغربي
وبالتالي هذا الراي العام خاصه الغربي منه
يضغط بهذا الاتجاه نرى بانه هنا مثلا في
اوروبا
وقعت عريضه لاكثر من نصف مليون شخص من قبل
اكثر من نصف مليون شخص على ضروره اغلاق
السفارات وطرد السفراء كذلك في همم
الاتحاد الاوروبي طالبات طالب عده
برلمانيين من ضمنهم برلمانيين ل- همم
مندوبين من من من المانيا ومن بلجيكا
باغلاق السفارات الايرانيه وطرد السفراء
واسحاق وسحب سفراء همم هذه الدول من ايران
هذه الخطوات من شانها ان تاتي
وليس المطالبات بضروره حضوره هؤلاء
الاشخاص في المحاكم الايرانيه لانه
بالتالير النظام الايراني لديه قانون او
القانون يقول بان اي شخص يقوم
نزاهه وشفافيه هذه التحقيقات وحياتييتها
النظام الايراني يقول بينهم من من يقوم
بالاحتجاج على المستوى الداخلي فهو يجب ان
ان توجه الى مساله محاربه الله والرسول
وزعزعه الاستقرار الداخلي وهذه التهم
عقوبتها الاعدام فلذلك حضور اشخاص من
مندوبين
السفارات لا لا يجدي نفعا بقدر ناس ضروره
البحث في عشان الايرانيه يعقوب سعيد من
امستردام
ونحن نستعد لليله الرياضيه منتخبيه
السعوديه وتونس في مواجهه حاسمه الليله
وبالتالي الجماهير العربيه
[موسيقى]
الثالثه
[تصفيق]
المنتخب السعودي يصل الدوحه محملا باعمال
كبرى
مهمه صعبه جدا بداها امام الارجنتين التي
تدخل كاس العالم كابرز المرشحين للقلقب
فوز تاريخي السعودي بهدفين لهدف
والاحتفالات تلف البلاد والعالم العربي
بعد اللقاء ب 4 ايام ممن لعبوا مباراه
الارجنتين يغيبون عن مواجهه بولندا
الاصابه تنهي مشوار القائد الفرج والمدافع
الشهراني في المونديال الخساره بهدفين
تصدم السعوديه مدربهم في المؤتمر يعلنها
لن ننتهي بعد
حتى يتاهل الاخضر من هذه المجموعه سيلاقي
المكسيك ان انتصر سيعبر بغض النظر عن
نتيجه الارجنتين امام بولندا اما انت عادا
فانه سينتظر فوز بولندا في اي نتيجه او
الخساره امام التانجو بفارق اربعه اهداف
غيابات السعوديه امام المكسيك لم تقتصر
على الفرج والشهراني انضم اليهم محمد
البريكي الموسى وعبد الاله الملكي الموقوف
بسبب الانذارات
جماهير السعوديه صنعت الحدث في الدوحه
لفتت الانتباه اليها بتفاعلها الكبير وسهم
في زياده شعبيه المنتخب السعودي وهو ما
دعى المدرب رونالدو للرهاني عليها في لقاء
المكسيك حين طلبها بالحضور ودعم الاخضر
[تصفيق]
[موسيقى]
كاس العالم هذا فهي فريق قوي للغايه مع
مهاجمين جيدين للغايه لذلك نحن على درايه
بكل شيء الان اعتقد ان الامر سيصل مساء
الغد الى الثواني الاخيره لان التشريق
سيكون في الملعبين لذا على الاشخاص الذين
يعانون من مشاكل قلبي ان يعتني بانفسهم
غدا
في مباراه يبحثوا فيها الطرفان عن تاكيد
احاقيته ما هو حجز مقعد في دور ال16 يلتقي
منتخب الارجنتين بنضي الهولندي
مباريات المجموعه الثالثه ايضا المنتخب
الارجنتيني يحتاج الى الفوز لضمان تاهله
بشكل المباشر او سيكفيه التعادل بشرط عدم
فوز المنتخب السعودي وسيكون هدف ميسي
ورفاقه الانتصار بكل تاكيد لاثبات جدارتهم
بترشح اللقب الكاس كاس العالم بالمقابل
سيحتاج المنتخب البولندي الى تعادلك اقل
احتمال للوصول الى الدور المقبل
محل الرياضي يعد البطيء اهلا بك كابتن
عادل يعني بدايه نبدا بالضغوط النفسيه
نعرف انه هذه المباراه حاسمه بالنسبه
للاعبين وكانه نهائي يعني وكانه هي دور
خروج المغلوب بشكل او باخر اام كيف يمكن
ان يكون الضغط عاليه على اللاعبين نحن
نعرف انه رونالدو افضل من حضر لاعبين بهذه
البطوله هو اكثر ما يتميز فيه رونالدو هو
الحاله النفسيه للاعبين لكن الحقيقه
الامور معقده ليش لانه عين في الملعب وعين
في الملعب اخر النتائج يعني الارقام او هي
من ستدد الامور معقده عنده ميزه للمنتخب
السعودي انه في حاله الفوز هو لا ينظر الى
اي نتيجه الملعب الاخر لا يعني ابدا لكن
داخل المباراه في توقيت واحد هي الصعوبه
هنا طيب هل يكفيني التعادل هل يكفيني طبعا
الفوز اكيد انظر ان نتيجه مباراه الاخرى
كل هذه الامور
عن النتائج في الملعب يطلع لكن اكيد عينه
على الدكه في كثير المرات لقيت دكه مثلا
يقول لك مثلا لو مصلحتنا احنا مثلا فوز
الارجنتين بعدد يقولوا اللاعبين لو بولندا
متقدمه ايضا يبلغ اللاعبين في اشياء حتى
اللاعب داخل الملعب يعني لا شعوري يكون مع
الخل مع انه الجهاز الاداري والفني يؤكد
على اللاعبين التركيز في الملعب ونسيان كل
ما يخص يعني احنا يعني اليوم المنتخب
السعودي يبحث عن نتيجه الفوز بتقول تاكيد
لكن اكيد ايضا عنده نتيجه تعادل قد تؤهله
في حال في حالات معقده زي ما قلت لك
ارقامه والارجنتين تفوز في نتيجه كبيره
يعني كل هذه الامور يعني هي متصعبه يعني
نحن لدينا معدلات الغيابات مثل المالكي او
بسبب الاصابه كيف يمكن ان همم يعني يتعامل
معها نار من ساء يضع مكان المالكي اولا في
اصابات وهي عمره صعب بصراحه بالذات
الكابتن ياسر الشهراني لانه ما في في
المملكه بشكل عام لا يقدر يعوض غياب ياسر
والدليل انه اصبح الاستعانه في محمد
البريك الظهير الايمن ايسر اصبح الاستعانه
في سعود عبد الحميد ايضا كظهير ايسر وهو
خانتا ايمن اذا غياب ياسر زائد الكابتن
سلمان الفرج اللي كان يؤدي يعني مع المدرب
اذا لاعب اربعه ثلاثه او اربعه اثنين
ثلاثه واحد سلماني الوحيد اللي يقدر يلعب
10 لعب نواف العابد ولعب سامي النججي ما
كانوا بالنسبه للمدير طيب ظروف هذه
المباراه قد تغير بعض الامور الفنيه من
خلال قراءه المدرب الكابتن رينارد للحاله
اليوم او الاحتياجات في مباراه اليوم
همم يعني كفى برايك سيدخل النار هذه همم
المباراه يعني اربعه ثلاثه مثلا او انه
يغير يعني احنا نعرف انه هذه الامور تعتمد
على جهازيه اللاعبين ايضا اتفق معك جاهزيه
اللاعبين وحاجتكم المباراه اليوم جاهزيه
اللاعبين تكلمنا عن سلمان انه يقدر يلعب
اي كان في مباراه السابق يلعب
اربعين طيب اليوم المباراه اتوقع انه بسبب
غياب المالكي يمكن يلعب اربع اعتقد انه
بيكون كانه ناصر الدوسري البديل اللي سته
همم قد يكون عبد الله عطيف او علي الحسن
مع اني انا مؤمن انه علي حسن هو ثمانيه
اكثر من سته هل بيلعب كانه هذه اعتبار
لكني اتوقع شخصيه انه يبدا 4-3 لاني انا
وش ابغى مباراه اليوم مباراه اليوم هي
اداره لانه كل ما تقدم منتخب المكسيكي
يبغى ايش مو بيفوز بهدف هو طموحهم يفوز
بعدد من الاهداف لكي يضمن تاهل لان
المكسيك لا سجل ولا استقبل في المباراتين
السابقه عشان كده هي عنده همم عفوا استقبل
هو في همم اقصد انا بولندا اللي همم لكن
اقصد من المكسيك يبحث عن تسجيل اهداف ليش
عشان يضمن يكون عندها اربع نقاط مع حصيله
اهداف اذا كل ما سجل بيتقدم اداره
المباراه حتى لو قبلنا لا سمح الله هدف
المفروض ايضا يكون الصبر والهدوء هو سنه
المنتخب عشان استدرج المنتخب نصف ملعبه
واستثمر سرعات اللاعبين سواء يعني سالم او
فراس او حتى صالح الشهري في كره القدم
المكسيكيه احنا شكرا اللاتينيه صعبه و
خاصيه جدا على المنخبه الاسيويه هم منتخب
شرس بصراحه وقوي ويتميز بالسرعه لكن هم
يمكن من اللاعبين اللي اطوالهم اقل يعني
هم اللي يجارونا في الامر هذا وقد تكون
احنا في كل المرات المباراتين السابقه
نخسر في الالعاب الهواء نخسر امام
المنتخبات لانهم قام
خاصه بولندا
الكره الارضيه للمنتخب السعودي واللي عليه
كلها يكسبها المنتخب البولندي وتشوفنا
تاثيرها اللي جاءت من النتائجها جيده
بالنسبه للمولوده او العكس كل هذه الامور
اليوم بتساعدنا لكن مش قصدي هم عندهم
السرعه ويلعبون على الاطراف بالمناسبه
يعني البولندا عكسه البولندا يلعب في
العمق وحتى همم الارجنتين يعني هي ماريا
وميسي وهم يلعبون تحت مارتينز لكن المكسيك
يلعب بشكل كبير على اطراف طيب احنا كيف
نستثمر هذا تبقى في ملعبك وتلعب الكره
الطويله للاستثمار الفرس المساحات موجوده
اليوم في دفاع او في منتصف ملعب المكسيك
هل نستثمرها بالشكل الصحيح مع ايماني انه
المطلوب اول 25 دقيقه اصله الوضوء
بس يعني انا لا احب ان اسال هذا السؤال
ولكن يعني ماذا تتوقع النتيجه اكيد اني
اتمنى فوز المنتخب عشان نطلع من اي حسابات
اخرى لكني في راي المبارات صعبه صعبه ان
شاء الله بالتوفيق نحنا بالتوفيق للمنتخب
السعودي طبعا ولا منتخب تونس الذي تنطلق
مباراته بعد قليل شكرا جزيلا لك عدد
المطيري
نهايه الموج الازرق
[موسيقى]
شكرا
وتونس كما ذكرنا في خبر عاجل قبل قليل
اصيب موظفا بانفجار رساله مفخخه في
السفاره الاوكرانيه في العاصمه الاسبانيه
مدريد وفرضت الشرطه طوقا امنيا في محيط
السفاره معلنه عن فتح تحقيق بالحادث وفي
اول تعليق على الانفجار طلب وزير الخارجيه
الاوكراني دنيتي كوليبا بزياده اجراءات
حمايه المباني دبلوماسيه والقنصليه
الاوكرانيه
وقبل قليل اعلنت بريطانيا فرض عقوباتنا
على 22 مسؤولا اشرف على عمليات التعبئه
العسكريه الجزئيه في روسيا فضلا عن نائب
رئيس الوزراء الروسيه وعشره حكام مناطق
وقال وزير الخارجيه البريطانيه جيمس كليفر
لان العقوبات تستهدف كل الذين تسببوا في
ارسال الاف الشباب الروس الى خطوط
المواجهه في الحرب باوكرانيا
ونبقى معكم في سياق نشره الخامسه من
العربيه ولدينا
معاناته مرضى السرطان في اليمن تتفاقم
وسبب حصار الحوثي
اهلا بكم من جديد حضر مسؤول سابقا في
تويتر
وذلك بسبب اداره الملك الجديد الماسك الذي
وصفها بدكتاتوريه وبالحديث عن القرارات
الجديده في تويتر اعلنت المنصه التراجع عن
سياستها لفحص الاخبار المضلله عن فيروس
كورونا مما يثير قلق الخبراء الذين حضروا
من عواقب هذه الخطوه
خطبه خطيره الى الوراء يحذر الاطباء الى
الماسك من خطبها في تويتر التنبيه واطلق
اثر تراجع شركه تويتر بعد ان اصبحت في
عصمه مالكها الجديد الملياردير الى الماسك
عن سياسه معالجه المعلومات المطله عن
فيروس كورونا قبل نشرها على المنصه ومع
اعلان تويتر لقرارها المفاجئ والذي ياتي
ضمن سلسله من القرارات التي وصفت بالجدليه
لماسك والتي يبدو ان جعبه الرجل مملوءه
بها اثيرا قلقوا مسؤولي الصحه في العالم
خاصه وان الفيروس باقي ويتمدد بل ويتسبب
بالموت احيانا ما قد يعني ان قرار ماسك
زاد ما خوف الخبراء من انتشار المرض بشكل
اوسع لتكبر احتمالات الوفيات بين المصابين
وبالعوده عامين الى الوراء
كانت الاشادات بالموقع الابرز في عالم
التواصل الاجتماعي تتكرر في كل مره يتصدى
للمعلومات المضله ويرفض نشرها في ذلك
الوقت اوقفت تويتر اكثر من 11,000 حساب
وازاله اكثر من مئه الف جزء من المحتوى
الانتهاكها السياسيه بعض تلك الحسابات
كانت تمتلكها شخصيات سياسيه
ومن اشهر الحسابات التي اغلقت كانت لعضوه
الحزب الجمهوري الامريكي ماروتشري اقتل
رجلين التي تم تعليق حسابها الشخصي في ذلك
الوقت لتشكيكها في فعاليه لقاحات فيروس
كورولا
الاسبوع الماضي حنان المصري العربي
[موسيقى]
اعلن وزير الطاقه السعوديه لامير عبد
العزيز بن سلمان اكتشاف حقليه غاز طبيعي
جديدين بالمنطقه الشرقيه باجماليه تدفقات
يزيد عن 52 مليون قدم مكعب يوميا وذكر في
بيان ان تدفق الغاز في الحقل اوتاد بمعدل
يصل الى 27 مليون قدم مكعبه قياسيه و900
برميل من المكثفات في اليوم بينما يصل حجم
تدفق الغاز في الحقل الدهناء الى 25 مليون
قدم مكعب قياسيه ونحو 500 برميل من
المكثفات يوميا واشار وزير الطاقه
السعوديه الى ان هذه الاكتشافات تعزز
احتياطيات المملكه في الغاز الطبيعي مما
يسهم في دعم استراتيجيات المملكه وتحقيق
اهدافه برنامج ازاحه الوقود السائل
ومن تقارير الخامسه الانسانيه تعاني اسر
كثيره مشقه سفر يستغرق ساعات طويله من عده
محافظات للوصول الى مركز لعلاج مرضى
السرطان في تعز وذلك بسبب الحصار الذي
تفرضه ميليشيا الحوثي على المحافظه لكن
المركز يعاني من نقص الادويه والمستلزمات
الطبيه ايضا
تتكبد اسر يمنيه عديده مشقه سفر ساعات
طويله ومضنيه عبر ما تيسر من طرقات تعبر
محافظه عده للوصول الى هذا المركز الخاص
بعلاج مرضى السرطان في تعز
صرخات الاطفال المرضى تملا المكان محاولات
تخفيف الامهم تصطدم بحاجز نقص الامكانيه
والادويه في ظل الاستمرار الحصار الذي
تفرضه منشيه الحوثي منذ اكثر من سبع سنوات
على الايام نشتري علاقت من خارج
وبتكالف كبيره
نعالجه هنا بالمركز اا
بس بعيد علينا الطريق بسبب اغلقت المنافذ
الصور وتتحدث عن نفسها المركز يستقبل 200
حاله يوميا في المتوسط اطفال وشباب وشيوخ
ياتون من عده محافظات مجاوره لتعز عبر طرق
الوعره المعاناه مضاعفه بين بعد المسافه
وقصر ذات اليد ونقص المستلزمات الطبيه
من الحديده حتى بالاماكن الاخرى بعيده عن
همم محافظه تعز هذه مشقه الطرق الا ان
هناك
يصلون الينا وبمشقه وهناك وناس يغلقون على
انفسهم ابواب بيوتهم لعدم قدرتهم على
الوصول الى مركز الامل
عدد من اصيب بالسرطان عام 2015 كان 15
الفا لكنه بلغ 30 الف عام 2022 في مختلف
المحافظات وفق احصاءات المؤسسه الوطنيه
لمكافحه السرطان في اليمن وفي انتظار فك
الحصار تستمر المعاناه والامل ايضا لعوده
البسمه الى وجوه هؤلاء الاطفال بلال
البوجداني العربيه
اعلن المتحدث العسكري المصري للقوات
المسلحه في بيان عن تنفيذي تدريب جوي مع
اليونان بمشاركه تشكيله من الطائرات
المقاتله متعدده المهام من الجانبين واضاف
ان التدريب المشترك من اثنين ياتي في اطار
دعم وتعزيز علاقات التعاون العسكري بين
البلدين
قالت صحيفه الاسرائيليه ان شركه اسرائيليه
لها مقارات في قبرص واليونان ارسلت تقنيات
واجهزه مراقبه متطوره لقوات الدعم السريع
بالسودان اضافت الصحيفه ان قوه الدعم
السريع بالسودان نقلت شحنه الاجهزه
الاسرائيليه لدى وصولها من الخرطوم الى
كارفور قبل ان ياخذ الجيش السوداني
معلومات بشانها واكدت الصحيفه الاسرائيليه
ان قوات الدعم السريع في السودان لديها
علاقات بشركات اسرائيليه عبر شبكه
يونانيين ووفقا
لثلاثه مصادر مستقله كانت الشحنه عباره عن
تقنيه مراقبه متطوره مصنوعه في الاتحاد
الاوروبي وبامكانها قلب ميزان القوه في
السودان بفضل قدرتها على تحويل الهواتف
الذكيه الى مخبرين صوتيين ومرئين لاصحابها
قتل مالا يقل عن 16 شخصان واصيبه 24 اخرون
في انفجار استهدف مدرسه دينيه شمال
افغانستان ذكرت مصادر وانا الانفجار وقع
في منطقه في منطقه ابيك عاصمه اقليم
وان العديد من المصابين في حاله خطره
ونبقى انسانيه ايضا في افغانستان فقط حلا
شتاء ثامن تحت سلطه طالبان في وقت اعلنت
الامم المتحده ان 79 بالمئه من الشعب
الافغاني لا يستطيعون الوصول الى معدلات
التدفئه في الشتاء الحالي
جولزرين يعيش مع اسرته على بعد امتار من
قصر الرئاسه في العاصمه كابول في هذه
المنازل الطينيه المتواضعه التي لا تقي
برد الشتاء اسرته جولزارين تعكس الحياه في
الكره الافغانيه التي يعيش فيها معظم
الشعب الافغاني
يقولذرين انه اطفاله السته جمع البلاستيكه
وقطعا من الحطب في الشوارع للتدفئه في هذا
الشتاء
وفصل الشتاء سوف يمر علينا بدون اي وسائل
تدفئه كما ترى ترى هناك قليل من البلاستيك
وليست عندنا وسائل اخرى للتدفئه
عائله فاطمه هي الاخرى التي تعيش في
العاصمه كابول قتل زوجها في عمليه تفجيريه
وهي كفيفه لديها خمسه من الاطفال الصغار
تقول ان جيرانها ساعدوها لتشتري كميه من
الفحم لا تكفيهم لاسبوع تشرح بالقليل منه
لتدفئه اطفالها
الجيران يساعدوننا احيانا ببعض الحطب
واحيانا كثيره لا ونحن في اكثر الاوقات لا
نحصل على التدفئه كيس واحد من الفحم لا
يكفي بالنسبه لطول الشتاء
والتي توصف بالطبقه السريه في افغانستان
فانها تعتمد على وسائل التدفئه مريحه لا
تخرج دخانا ولا تحدث ازعاجا تشتغل اكثر
بالحطب وبعضها بالوقود ولكننا نفقاتها
باهظه
اصله الشتاء طويل
جدا
ونقوم بها في حرق الحطب ونشكر الله على
هذه الوسائل فان الشتاء في افغانستان قارس
جدا وقد اعلن مكتب الامم المتحده لتنسيق
المساعدات الانسانيه اوتشا ان 79% من سكان
افغانستان يعيشون في ملاجئ مؤقته ومنازل
شبه مدمره هذا الشتاء
فصل الشتاء في افغانستان بارد وممطر مليء
بالمصاعب في وقت تحذر المؤسسات الامميه من
الشيطان الحالي سيكون تحديا اضافيا
لتحديات اليوميه للشعب الافغاني افضل هذه
العربيه كابول
ما في تقرير صادم عن مستقبل الديمقراطيه
في العالم النشره المعهد الدولي
للديمقراطيه والمساعده الانتخابيه الذي
يتخذ من السويد مقر له ان نصف الديمقراطيه
في العالم تشهد تراجعا في نظامها السياسي
متاثره بشكل لافت بالحرب في اوكرانيا
والازمه الاقتصاديه العالميه كما حذر امين
عام المعهد كيفن كاسس زموره من ان وضع
الولايات المتحده في هذا الشان على قدر
خاص من الخطوره في تقليد الديمقراطيه
لديها واصبحت في مصافي دول كسبادور
والبرازيل والمجر وابقى زموره
[تصفيق]
[موسيقى]
نهايه نشاط الخامسه من العربيه ولكن خدمات
العربيه مستمره دوما على مدار الساعه
[موسيقى]
[تصفيق]